there's this other aspect we've talked  about which princeton has studied which  is  whose  goals  are more likely to be made policy and in  that sense the us hasn't really been a  representative democracy for a long time  wherein the the policy goals  of the rich and of big corporations are  far more likely to be made law than  those of the average person i mean you  know you look at things like is the  estate tax the estate tax in which an  individual has an 11 million dollar  exemption and a couple has 22 million  dollars in exempt um  money that they can pass to heirs  tax-exempt money  that benefits a very small portion of  people  and yet it has been a mainstay in some  form or another to some degree or  another for a long time